what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the new villains that are
going to play a central role in season
four of the my hero academia anime I am
talking about the Shia ha psyche also
known as the eight precepts of death in
this video I will be breaking down who
they are one by one and I will also
explain the true nature of every single
one of their quirks I hope that having
all of this information right here in
one place will be useful to you and that
you will be able to come back to this
video every time you need a quick
refresher about each villain and their
unique quirk if you've been enjoying the
boku no hero content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications that way you will actually
be notified whenever we upload a new
boku no hero video you could also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar quick heads up this video will
include information on the back story
and quirk of each member of the eight
precepts of death with that said I will
not be spoiling the actual plot of
season 4 and I will not reveal what
ultimately happens to each one of these
characters the eight precepts of death
is one of numerous Yakuza groups who
used to control the criminal underworld
in Japan the Yakuza refers to a
collection of criminal organizations who
used to operate in Japan and who abide
by a strict code of conduct that
distinguishes them from regular
criminals this fictional Yakuza is of
course based on the real-life Yakuza
also known as the Japanese mafia
although it was once a powerful
organization in the world of boku no
hero the Yakuza has been severely
weakened and rendered virtually useless
by the rise of the hero society in short
once heroes like all might emerged with
incredible superhuman powers at their
disposal thanks to their quirks the
Yakuza could not compete and they
eventually lost their influence and
relevance the leader of the eight
precepts was a man known only as the
boss and he was the one who ran the
organization before overhaul in fact he
was the one who took overhaul in and
raised him within the organization when
overhaul was still a child
eventually the boss became
sick and bedridden and overhauled took
control of the eight precepts the name
eight precepts of death appears to be a
reference to the eight precepts in
Buddhism which are eight rules or
guidelines for how a devout follower of
Buddhism should behave on observance
days and during festivals however as you
will see throughout the course of this
video
members of the eight expendables which
is a subgroup within the eight precepts
of death actually invert the original
Buddhist precepts in this video I will
be covering all of the known members of
the eight precepts and their quirks but
there are also unnamed grunts who are
largely irrelevant so I will not be
spending any time on them also since we
don't know much about the original boss
we don't even know his name or the
nature of his quirk let's jump right
into overhaul the current leader of the
eight precepts and dedicated germophobe
overhaul real name chi chi sake hates
what the hero society has become and how
it has destroyed the power and influence
of the yakuza overhaul is committed to
doing whatever it takes to destroy the
hero society and bring the yakuza back
to its former glory and he eventually
concludes that the best way to achieve
his goals is to find a way to eradicate
quirks
he believes that quirks are a disease
that has infected humanity and he
believes that the only way to stop the
disease is to find a way to eliminate
quirks in order to accomplish this
overhaul is willing to conduct some of
the most deranged experiments imaginable
including experiments on innocent people
but despite his borderline psychotic
behavior overhaul still commands an
immense amount of loyalty within the
eight precepts and in fact many of its
members would not hesitate to give up
their lives for overhaul so it is clear
that despite his cruelty and arrangement
overhall possesses strong leadership
skills and he is highly revered among
the members of his organization the name
of his quirk is also overhaul and it
allows its user to disintegrate anything
he touches as long as he touches it with
at least one of his fingers he can kill
someone instantly by simply
disintegrating them but if overhaul
chooses to reassemble someone right
after disintegrating them he can
actually bring them back to life he is
able to control how much of his targets
body is actually disintegrated and if he
chooses not to kill someone but just
break down parts of their body he can
then reassemble those parts and all of
the past injuries and illnesses within
that part of the body will be cured
overhauls incredible disassembling and
reassembling quark can also be used on
inorganic matters such as walls and the
earth which allows them to disassemble
and reassemble the entire battlefield
around him and gain a great advantage
over his opponent finally if he
disassembles parts of his own body at
the same time as parts of someone else's
body he can reassemble them in a way
that essentially fuses the two people
together which creates a fused and even
more overpowered version of himself it
goes without saying that overhaul has
one of the most overpowered quirks in
all of boku no hero but even a quirk
that is as opie as this one does have
some weaknesses overhaul must make
direct contact with his target with at
least one of his bare fingers in order
to activate the quark if you can disable
his hands or prevent him from touching
you with his bare fingers in some way
you will be able to avoid his quirk
using his quirk also appears to give
overhaul an itchy rash but that may be
simply a side effect of overhauls
germophobia rather than a direct result
of his quirk at any rate overhauls
ability to destroy and put back together
everything around him including
inorganic objects human bodies and even
his own body makes his quirk one of the
absolutely strongest in the entire
series if you want to know more about
overhaul in particular I made an entire
video just on him so you can check that
out link in the description in that
video I said that if it gets 5,000 likes
I will drop a whole video on arey right
away as of the making of this video we
have about 4500 likes so if you want to
see the video Neri head over there and
drop that like now let's talk about
chrono stasis overhauls assistant within
the 8 precepts his real name is Hadi
Carano and he has been a close friend of
overhaul for many years as such chrono
stasis is fully aware of overhauls plans
including the darkest aspects of these
plans but he still willingly follows
overhaul and faithfully carries out the
duties as overhauls assistant chrono
stasis often witnesses overhauls cruel
treatment of other people but he doesn't
seem to have any issues with the wave
overhaul behaves which implies that
chrono stasis is himself a cruel and
cold-hearted person his quirk also named
chrono stays
I know not very original works on the
basis of slowing down time so basically
his hair is shaped like the needles of a
clock which can extend far beyond his
body if he can hit an opponent with one
of these needles the opponent's
movements will be slowed down so
essentially the opponent will be moving
in slow motion and a fast hero will
suddenly begin moving like a snail the
effect of this quirk is very useful in
battle but it is of course temporary one
weakness of the quirk is that the user
has to remain motionless while using it
this means that chrono stasis has to
find a way to catch his opponent by
surprise because if they know what's
coming and they move out of the quirks
range chrono stasis will be unable to
follow his target and use the quirk at
the same time next up let's talk about
mimic real name joy ear Anaka mimic
appears to be the one who handles the
financial aspects of the organization's
activities and we often see him counting
mad stacks of cash like chrono stasis
mimic is very loyal to overhaul and he
becomes furious if anyone tries to
insult his boss he has a very unique
work that allows him to be incredibly
stealthy but he also has a bad temper
and he can be provoked into making
foolish mistakes in battle if the
opponent knows how to push his buttons
the name of his quirk is mimicry and it
allows mimic to transfer his mind and
body into inanimate objects and then
control those objects as if they were
part of his actual body
mimics quirk is limited in the sense
that he can only transfer his body into
an object roughly the size of a
refrigerator but if he increases the
power of his quirk using quirk enhancing
drugs he can control much larger objects
such as the entire floor of a building
with that said when he is possessing an
object mimic appears to have limited
sensory perception and he is sometimes
forced to partially emerge from the
object he is possessing in order to
fully grasp the situation or to
communicate something to someone else
when he does this he is more vulnerable
to attack by his opponents along with
the boss who is currently indisposed
overhaul chrono stasis and mimic formed
the upper echelon of the eight precepts
of death but now let's talk about the
eight expendables a subgroup within the
eight precepts recruited by overhaul
personally in order to serve him with
total dedication commitment to his call
first up let's talk about shin Nemoto
a former con artist who is fiercely
loyal to overhaul shin has an
interesting quirk called confession
which compels everyone to answer his
questions truthfully as such confession
allows its user to discern the innermost
thoughts secrets and motivations of
everyone around him because of this
unique ability Shin realized how
dishonest manipulative and insincere
most people were constantly lying and
hiding their true intentions in order to
get ahead shin feels that overhaul the
man who recruited him into the 8
precepts is the only sincere person that
he's ever met in his life and this is
part of the reason why Shin is so loyal
to overhaul shins quirk confession is
extremely useful for any criminal
organization since it can be used to
gather valuable Intel manipulate people
determine whether anyone is planning
anything behind the boss's back and so
on
for this reason overhaul has come to
recognize the value of Shin and his
abilities and Shin believes himself to
be special among the 8 Expendables
because of how much value overhaul
places in him and his quirk because his
quirk doesn't have any offensive
capabilities Shin carries a handgun and
simply shoots his opponents when he has
to I honestly don't know why every
villain doesn't do the exact same thing
at all times I mean I can understand
that heroes might not want to carry
firearms because they don't want to
accidentally hit an innocent bystander
and so they rely on the power of their
quirks but villains who don't care about
bystanders could all just be carrying
machine guns at all times I mean just
imagine Moneta facing down a villain and
Mina ties like wait until I get you with
my sticky balls and the villain just
pulls out a shotgun so much for all
those years of intense hero training
Shin squirt is an inversion of the
Buddhist preset to abstain from false
speech ie from lying shins clerk
prevents others from lying to him but he
still lies deceives and manipulates
others all the time next up let's talk
about kendo rapa another member of the
8th Expendables rapa is a vicious and
bloodthirsty man who loves to fight he
is always looking for a good fight and a
worthy opponent
he thinks that using weapons in battle
is dishonorable so he chooses
to fight exclusively with his fists this
actually works really well with his
quirk the name of which is strong arm
and which enables rapid to move his
shoulders extremely quickly and with
great power which lets him attack his
enemies with porridges of punches in
sharp contrast to the other Expendables
and to the wider eight precepts
organization rapa isn't blindly loyal to
overhaul in fact rapid joined the
organization because overhaul was able
to defeat him in battle and rap as
motivation for being in the 8th
Expendables
is just so he could get a chance to
fight overhaul again rapa relishes in a
good fight especially a fight with high
stakes such as a fight to the death with
that in mind
roppa has great respect for those who
are brave enough to stand up to him and
put up a good and fair fight against him
rappers quirk and personality are an
inversion of the Buddhist precept to
abstain from taking life roppa is
vicious and loves fighting to the death
using his deadly quirk then we have
Hecky g10 guy 10 guy is a calm and
composed member of the 8 Expendables and
in some ways he is the polar opposite of
Rapa Tang guy wants to complete the
missions of their organization as
quickly and efficiently as possible
any things that excessive violence and
taking pleasure in fighting our lowbrow
and unworthy pursuits the name of ten
guys quirk is barrier and it enables its
user to generate a telekinetic
dome-shaped barrier around him the
barrier that Tang guy generates is
extremely strong and it has been
compared to punching a steel wall the
barrier can vary in size but it cannot
extend too far beyond where ten guys
standing because the barrier appears
exactly where he is located ironically
despite being polar opposites Rafa and
Tang guy often fight together as a team
this is because rappers offense and tang
guy's defense tend to work extremely
well in combination with each other
while this works well in theory the
vastly different personalities of rappin
tang guy can lead to the kind of
disagreements that devolve into outright
conflict between them it is important to
note that despite being extremely strong
Tang guys barrier is not indestructible
and if he himself is weakened enough he
will no longer be able to use his quirk
Tang guys quirk is an inversion of the
Buddhist precepts pain from taking
shelter under a luxurious can of
thank ice quirk allows him to shelter
himself under a powerful barrier next up
we have rikiya katsu , a villain who can
only be described as a huge buff Chad he
is incredible physical strength even
without accounting for his quirk and he
is able to tear down entire walls with
his immense power the name of his quark
is vitality stealing and if he touches
someone and then inhales he will
basically suck in and absorb the
vitality ie the energy of others this
means that IKEA grows stronger as his
opponents grow weaker the more energy he
absorbs from others the bigger and
stronger he becomes because his quark
requires physical contact to activate
normally if you restrain rikiya he will
not be able to use his quark but if he
uses a quark enhancing drug in order to
boost his power
rikiya can absorb the energy of multiple
people in the immediate area around him
without even touching them all he has to
do is inhale and he suddenly becomes
incredibly powerful and capable of
taking on multiple top-ranked pro heroes
on his own the Kia's overall power after
boosting it with a quark enhancing drug
is not only slightly but rather
exponentially greater than it would have
been on its own the kiosk work appears
to invert the Buddhist precept about
abstaining from intimate contact his
quark allows him to drain the life force
of his opponents similar to the idea of
an incubus a male demon who drains the
life energy of women through intimate
contact the female version of the
Incubus is of course a succubus now
let's talk about Toya setsuna he is
another villain who was recruited into
the 8th Expendables by overhaul directly
Toya had a difficult life and at one
point he was cheated on and betrayed by
his lover which led him to falling in
debt he tried to commit suicide but
failed after a pro hero came along and
saved him but despite getting a second
chance at life
Toya still felt lost and worthless after
losing everything he had nowhere to go
and he had no purpose in his life
then one day overhaul came along and
gave him a purpose by inviting him to
join the 8 precepts of death because
overhaul found Toya and gave him a
purpose when he was at his lowest Toya
feels a zealous loyalty towards overhaul
and he is willing to do anything to
protect his bond
the name of Toya's quirk is larceny and
it enables him to instantly snatch an
object that someone else is holding and
bring it over into his own hands the
core can be used to snatch the weapons
of other people such as guns or even the
manifestations of someone's quirks such
as sun-eater's food based battle
accessories this quirk actually reminds
me of bonds ability in the seven deadly
sins or kazuma's panty snatching
abilities in kono Suba the limitations
of this quirk include a size limit the
object cannot be impossibly large or
heavy also Toya has to see the object
that he wants to steal if his sight is
obstructed in some way then he cannot
use his quirk effectively nevertheless
the quirk is extremely useful for
disarming and confusing opponents Toya's
quirk inverts the Buddhist precept of
abstaining from taking what is not given
since his quirk allows him to do
precisely that to take from others what
they do not want him to have then we
have you Hojo
a member of the eighth Expendables who
often fights alongside Toya the name of
use quirk is crystallization and it
allows him to produce powerful crystals
from his body including covering his
entire body in these crystals if he
chooses due to nature of his quirk in
the past you had a job producing crystal
gems for someone who wanted to sell them
as precious stones but then it turned
out that the crystals used quirk
produced weren't very valuable and you
was cast aside and abandoned by the
people yet worked for just like Toya you
felt lost and worthless and without a
purpose in life and that is when
overhaul found him and recruited him
into the eight presets
offering him a purpose and a sense of
belonging use quirk is very durable and
versatile and he can even produce
weapons such as swords out of his
crystals and then use them against his
opponents but despite being strong and
durable his crystals are not
indestructible use quirk is an inversion
of the Buddhist precept of abstaining
from wearing ornaments and decorations
since his quirk allows them to produce
crystals all over his body and crystals
are closely associated with jewelry next
up let's talk about sodomy truth table a
a man who appears to be mentally
unstable the name of his quirk is food
and it allows him to bite off chew and
basically eat virtually anything that
crosses his path he is always hungry and
his stomach is apparently a
bottomless pit so he's able to chew and
devour everything in sight and the only
way to avoid this quirk is to stay away
from his massive mouth because the
nature of his quirk and his insatiable
appetite and mental instability table I
felt rejected and shunned by society
when he was lost and hopeless overhaul
found him and took him in this turned
Taba into a die hard and extremely loyal
follower overhaul and Taba is willing to
give anything including his own life in
order to serve his boss but besides just
overhaul
Taub is also close to an extremely loyal
to his fellow Expendables including you
and Toya Tabas quirk and personality
constitute an inversion of the Buddhist
precept of stain from the
overconsumption of food top is always
hungry and can devour anything that
crosses his path and finally we have day
dosa cocky a man whose quirk an entire
lifestyle are directly dependent on
alcohol the name of his quirk is sloshed
a term for being drunk tanned my friends
and I used to use back in high school
and the power of this quirk is to make
anyone who comes close to so cocky start
feeling as drunk as Saki currently is so
basically if Saki gets drunk then
everyone who comes close to him will
also feel drunk and they will lose their
sense of balance their movements will
become sluggish and so on while this is
a useful quirk in terms of
incapacitating your opponents it is also
a quirk with a massive drawback in order
to use it you basically have to turn
yourself into an alcoholic which is
definitely not something that I would
recommend to anyone call me crazy but I
feel like this guy would be much more
effective as a villain if he just stayed
sober and used a baseball bat or
something
sokka case quirk is an inversion of the
Buddhist rule to abstain from consuming
intoxicating drinks and drugs and those
are all the known members of the eight
precepts of death and their quirks
explained I hope you enjoyed having all
of this information right here in one
place and by all means let me know who
is your favorite member of the eight
precepts and which of their quirks do
you like the most personally I think
overhauls quirk is one of the best in
the entire series but some of these
other quirks are pretty freaking cool
too hit me up with your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more boku
here content on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications the way that YouTube works
if you don't turn on all notifications
you will not be notified they're gonna
bury our videos so if you want to see
more turn on all notifications thank you
so much you can check me out on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar for all
the latest boku no hero news and updates
I want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime out pro patrons who make
videos like this one possible special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress on hell Cruz stealers poet
Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat a karate
on Anatole Cassatt's ki TJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam
Maddy Mac makoto-kun and your voice Seth
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they add some value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our page and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]